hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before you do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 what
I'm doing in my text community is
bonkers it's instant it's access it's
exclusive and now enjoy this YouTube
videos
Gary babe there is underpriced places I
know a lot how many people by show of
hands have heard me over the last six
months pound into your [ __ ] skull
tick-tock and LinkedIn raise your hands
keep them up stand up stand up if you've
heard it I want you to stand up don't
[ __ ] me stand up now I'm about to
physically through this craze like
here's the fist like this is crazy
but this amount of people have heard me
pounding into their skull for six months
there's underpriced attention on
LinkedIn and tick tock if I told you the
amount of collective content in this
entire room combined of posts on
LinkedIn and tick-tock over the last six
months is so small it would break your
heart I am giving the [ __ ] game away
for free and you mother [ __ ] aren't
executing you got your perspective
be happy don't you want to be happy
[Music]
what's up that's good LA thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you so
much yes right sit down let's do this
Thanks do this good afternoon good
afternoon so right for him to be up
there thanks for having me
throw up the dubs super excited to be
here let's let's uh let's get settled I
want to give as much value as I can so
several things I want to talk about this
afternoon you know when I think about
speaking to crowds where I know a lot of
people in it have consumed the content
what I always try to challenge myself
into is what nuance you know what
what tidbit what extra thing can I bring
up and most importantly what am I seeing
right this second I think the thing that
has allowed me to have certain success
is my ability to be pretty
one-dimensional honestly and that one
dimension is when I produce content when
I build businesses when I think about
what everybody in this room wants which
is some sort of balance between
happiness and success however they
define it what has worked for me over
the last 20 years and what a
replicatable moment or thesis or
execution that would play for this
audience and for me that thing more than
anything by far is where is the
attention of the consumer that we're all
trying to reach whether you're trying to
get somebody to vote for you for mayor
of your town or raise money for a
non-profit or sell your sneaker or your
real estate fund or whatever you may be
in - the reality is before you can close
someone to create an action that is in
your vested interest you have to have
their attention and what I've basically
been doing for 20 plus years is
following attention and I've done that
in places that I
think our underpriced at that moment
obviously the number one moved for all
of us in marketing to make something
happen is to buy a Superbowl commercial
because the reality is every American
will see it whether they watch it on
YouTube before the game or during the
game the other reality is most of us
can't dole out the 30 million dollars to
do that because it not only costs six
million to buy it and a million or two
to make it but then you have to buy
another twenty or thirty million dollars
worth of TV from Fox or CBS or ABC or
whoever has the game so recognizing that
this room is not gonna buy a Super Bowl
spot and run a commercial for 30 seconds
to tell the world what they're about or
what they want them to do or know about
I then start thinking about how I built
my career when I had no money and it was
about doing an e-commerce site in 1997
or whether it was doing email or them
probably the thing that really hits
scale for me back in the day in 2000
2001 which was buying Google AdWords for
5 and 10 cents a click when nobody
thought one of the reasons that and a
lot of you know me for this one of the
reasons I was really kind of a winner in
social in 2006 7 8 9 10 11
was because I'd learned those lessons
already in the late nineties around
email and search and I just understood
that the attention would move to this
thing by the way it's the reason and I
know a lot of you know this about me if
you follow me it's the reason I keep
spitting and keep pushing and keep
talking about voice devices because I
genuinely believe that one of the things
that allows me the great luxury of being
able to speak in front of you tonight
was how right I was about this and I
want to remind people there's a lot of
youngsters in here but from so some of
us oh geez we know a lot of people
didn't want this they were thrilled with
their blackberry they loved the fact
that they didn't have to look at their
phone and they could type because they
knew the keyboard like as crazy as this
may sound for a lot of this room most
people were not as bullish on the iPhone
as a lot of you would think and for me I
understood once the Internet now was
with us at all times all sorts of things
were gonna happen and just to make it
very simple pre iPhone internet on your
phone there
No Ober there is no Instagram there is
no everything that we kind of know today
and so I know that the Boise device the
Alexa the Google home the Apple pod is
gonna be that next play for us over the
next decade because all of you are gonna
talk to that thing and do things you now
do on your phone and that will all lead
us down one big path of actually
building a brand not being a salesperson
so that's something to keep in mind but
I will tell you this before we get into
the heady stuff of that one of the
things that I always think about is how
basic my advice really is but how
undisciplined or how difficult it is for
many mentally and emotionally to
actually execute on it I'm gonna make
this very simple I believe every person
in this room this evening needs to
produce close to 100 pieces of content a
day it's not super complicated like I
don't have that much else to really say
here this evening I believe that the far
majority of you need to produce that
much content today around whatever
you're trying to achieve right whatever
your goals are obviously I think a lot
about Jab Jab Jab right hook which is
Gib Gib Gib and then ask and so that's
my framework not super complicated again
what has transpired in my own personal
content over the last three years is why
don't you do that how many people here
to consume my content for the most part
thank you thank you and that feels
amazing but would feel way more amazing
if I actually knew that most of you were
doing what I've been saying and the
reality is it's completely the reverse
for all the hands that just went up so
many people get thrilled and fired up
when they hear me talk they they feel
good about it they like it it feels good
we have a good I can feel the
relationship I have with you right now
it feels good what's gotten me into
places I never thought that I would talk
about with my content like parenting and
and so many other things is why are you
not posting a hundred times a day like
you know like it's you know this is
something that I am probably gonna spend
all of 2020 finding different ways to
ask
this same very simple question why you
know it works for me you know it works
for so many others that you want the
same results for what level of
insecurity about the way you look about
negative what cripples you when people
spit hate or push back against you like
wait what have you not found the thing
that you actually like making content
around I think one of the big things
that I have to get back to is the
revelation that the reason it's so easy
for me to go so hard and do so much is I
love the [ __ ] I do I mean it and I think
and I think and I appreciate that
response and I think a lot of the
reaction just now I think we can all
admit to ourselves if we're being honest
with ourselves a lot of the businesses
and a lot of the ventures that a lot of
people get into is because they're
chasing where they think the money is a
lot of people have found themselves in
crypto in cannabis in social in many
other places because they hear or they
assume that the money's there
they're not doing it they love it
they're doing it because they think the
money's there for me the great fortune
is I don't necessarily love any product
obviously there's things I'm more into
than others obviously I fell in love
over time with wine because it was my
family business obviously when I do the
case Westing I love sneaker culture
that's cool
right you know the sports cart thing is
a layup for me I'm so thrilled that I
think it's gonna have a little bit of a
run cuz that comes natural to me I like
that but there's a ton of things that I
know are gonna do well financially
that I don't get excited about I think I
think you know this I don't get excited
about real estate it is historically a
great place to be and I don't get
excited about Wall Street and buying
stocks it's a historically a great place
to be in you don't see me overly talking
about it or being passionate about it
it's just cuz I don't like it it's not
the thing that I get excited about it's
not the place that gets me going and I'm
not gonna be able to go hard for fifteen
hours a day around that subject matter
so where this all goes for me is very
simple I genuinely believe that people
that come to a conference of this nature
more often
not unfortunately in my opinion are
looking for a hack I really believe that
you know take it for what it is I'm
coming from a place of love not coming
from a place of negativity I think
people are looking for the hack the
shortcut I'm just telling this whole
[ __ ] room
there's no [ __ ] hack like there's no
shortcut
there's no [ __ ] magic system if there
was a magic system everybody would
[ __ ] do it what there is is
self-awareness what there is is patience
with where there what there is more than
anything and something that I have to
figure out over the next decade how to
do a better job of which is perspective
somebody asked me a question today and
I'm like right because I think I have a
lot of time all of a sudden everything
gets easier there are so many people
under here here under how many people
under 30 raise your hands
this [ __ ] crew I love you [ __ ] so
much and I equally want to punch you in
your [ __ ] mouth
and and I don't actually want to punch
you in the mouth I want to punch you in
the mouth with some sense around the
fact that let me promise you this you're
not finished when you turn 30 so many of
you are so [ __ ] scared of that number
[ __ ] that number that number means that
you haven't even started that means
you're in the first quarter with the way
that modern medicine is going you
[ __ ] are probably gonna live to
120 like I don't know what you're so
scared well let me rephrase I've come to
learn by reading hundreds of thousands
of DMS I know what you're scared of
you're scared about what other people
think about you everything I talk about
is super simple
unfortunately it breaks for almost
everybody because they care about what
people think about them we are living in
the greatest era of keeping up with the
Joneses cuz the Joneses live on social
24/7 and everybody is in FOMO all the
time always mass levels of insecurity
comparing themselves to others for no
[ __ ] reason
[Applause]
the the best thing that happened to me
was that I worked 15 hours a day six and
a half days a week for 12 years until I
was 34 and didn't talk to nobody about
nothing about anything you know I have
empathy I have empathy for a lot of any
people in here who are massively
ambitious and get caught up way too
early to talk about we've got 22 year
old coaches and experts and there's 22
year old life coaches [ __ ] you
haven't lived you have any [ __ ]
started anyway here's the punchline
there's under placed place I basically
have come to realize actually I do do
real estate I just don't buy land and
property
i buy attention what I'm good at is I'm
good at buying Facebook aka beachfront
property in Malibu before anybody
understood it today the number one thing
I can give you tangibly not you know a
lot of people like Gary B you just
talked about um I'm thrilled to go
tactical I'm thrilled to go macro it's
all clouds and dirt that's why I think
about it that's why I use that
terminology
it's those nobody in here wants to be in
the middle you need to be way up here
philosophically so you have a strategy
about your life what do you like what
are you actually trying to achieve my
life is so simple the reason I'm
executing so hard is I know my macro I
professionally and selfishly I want to
buy the New York Jets and when a [ __ ]
Super Bowl and and in the selfless
altruistic part I want to be the
greatest entrepreneur and give back the
most by giving the most to everybody
with no ask in return super simple
as you can imagine that makes it very
easy for me to navigate all my decisions
I don't judge how anybody else rose
everybody else can do what they're doing
but for me if I want to do that the way
I produce my content the way I roll the
way I give away everything for you
should see this deck I'm about to come
out with d-roc when's it gonna be done a
couple next week like I'm about to put
out this thing that is gonna [ __ ]
piss off everybody because most people
would have sold it for three thousand
bucks and I'm putting out for free and
we put thousands of hours against it and
I'm gonna [ __ ] up the system that's how
I like to do it but but but that's
because I understand my macro I
understand that I want the statues I
don't need the extra zeros in my bank
account I can do that without your money
that's what I know how to do but by the
way and everybody here can do whatever
you want do what you do who the [ __ ] am
i everybody do like I'm not judging
I actually don't give a [ __ ] you need to
do you but let me tell you this let me
tell you what's happening there is
underpriced places I know a lot how many
people by show of hands have heard me
over the last six months pound into your
[ __ ] skull tick-tock and LinkedIn
raise your hands
keep them up stand up stand up if you've
heard it I want you to stand up don't
[ __ ] me
stand up now I'm about to physically
through this crate like here's the fist
like this is crazy but this amount of
people have heard me pounding into their
skull for six months
there's underpriced attention on
linkedin and tick tock if I told you the
amount of collective content in this
entire room combined of posts on
LinkedIn and tick-tock over the last six
months is so small it would break your
heart that is what I have to figure out
that is what I've not been able to
unlock just yet this is each percent of
this [ __ ] room and there's people in
here gravity you can sit down and you
can ask there's not even pursue this
room and of that there's a heavy
percentage of people here who haven't
posted five times yet on tick tock who
haven't posted ten times on LinkedIn I
am giving the [ __ ] game away for free
and you mother [ __ ] aren't executing
I need to figure this out and that is
what I'm spending my mission on why is
it because the ambition coming out of
your mouth isn't followed up by actual
action yes is it because you actually
don't have anything to talk about you
know one of the things that we have to
all collectively take a step back on is
what do we talk about you know one of
the luxuries up you know how fun it is
to talk about business building when
you've actually built big businesses you
know many people talk about building
businesses but I've never built a
business they just sell the business of
building businesses so for me you need
to figure out what I keep telling kids
that are trying to be experts [ __ ] being
an expert document going through it the
most interesting thing a 26 year old can
tell me is living the life of a 26 year
old and what's fresh and what's poppin
and what's corny and what's good and
what's bad and what's hard we need to be
in a documenting society not in a
pontificating about [ __ ] you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
Society you like that that's funny it's
true I watch every day I consume content
of like people comment like people are
talking out of their ass people know the
[ __ ] they're talking about you might
people in here have opinions about tick
tock and never posted once you know many
people here have no clue about the stuff
they talk about we need to become
practitioners my friends the thing that
helps me have any audacity or the fire
I'm trying to spit up here is I'm doing
it every day I'm creating content every
day I'm running ads every day then I
have a company called vaynermedia that's
running a billion dollars in ads I'm
looking at data I'm seeing the variables
I know for everybody in here who's
trying to run Instagram swipe up ads and
it's not working it's not instagrams
fall it's your contents fall the
variable in your six success is your
content
not the platforms this is a foregone
conclusion Facebook dominates 45 to 90
year olds it works every time
but is your video good enough is your
picture good enough is your headline
good enough you might people hear what a
pop on Instagram but mail in the copy
and they spend an hour and a half on the
photo when the copy is half the battle
there's so much confusion in the system
right now my friends and this is all
happening during a phenomenally good
economy let me let me let me give it to
you in a way that's not fun to deliver
if you're not winning right now you're
in trouble
cuz it's [ __ ] easy out there the
economy's frothy as [ __ ] there's money
being thrown around left and right
carelessly the internet is still super
underrated and if you know if you're
here you know about it and there's still
a lot that don't if you're not winning
right now you need to take a step back
and realize you're either not in the
right genre or not selling the right
thing or you might have to realize you
might just not be an entrepreneur which
is amazing there's nothing wrong with
not being one the number four and the
number nine and the number thirteen and
Netflix and Facebook made a lot more
than a number one in a hundred percent
of the companies this is one humongous
game of self-awareness there is a reason
that you're not posting the level of
content there is a reason you don't have
a podcast there is a reason you don't
have a vlog and it stems from you're not
comfortable producing and whether that
is because your mom was [ __ ] up and
she [ __ ] you up whether that's you're
in a place where you just actually have
nothing to say yeah and actually have to
live for another decade to put out stuff
whether that is you don't fully believe
it or what I'm most worried about cuz
I'm really starting to look at this
action you're just looking for it to
happen too fast I produced Wine Library
TV five days a week for three years and
nobody cared five days a week three
years I spent seven eight hours a day on
Twitter in two thousand seven eight nine
seven eight I used to go to sleep at
four o'clock in the morning those years
because I had to work my whole job and I
believe
so much in social and nobody knew who
the [ __ ] I was so I had to go into every
single conversation about wine and I
didn't go in there and tell him to buy
from wine library
I read going to Napa this weekend by
some random tech executive and I would
jump in and literally explain to her six
wineries she should check out email
Whitehall Lane and say hey can you give
this person a VIP I would spend 19
minutes 19 minutes trying to set up this
random person's VIP wine tours in Napa
just to create context with one person
it would blow your mind to know how many
people here ever spent 19 minutes period
engaging with random people on Twitter
to build awareness a stunningly small
percentage of this audience because
nobody wants to do that work cuz it's
hard everybody wants to make some
miraculous piece of content that's gonna
make them viral and make them rich to
buy a [ __ ] island in Jamaica and
smoke weed all day hey guys sorry to
interrupt your video I'm just giving you
this call for my number to let you know
that you have to join my text community
to one two nine three one five seven
three one two hit me up with a text
everybody sees it now everybody sees it
now people see the results that classic
[ __ ] thing where they show like the
iceberg and you see the you know that
[ __ ] photo that [ __ ] is real people
see it now people are confused about how
much time and effort and work it's put
in it takes a lot of work to produce ten
different pieces of content to put on
LinkedIn every single day about your
craft that takes work I just we listened
and we were living at a time right now
where hustle culture is getting [ __ ] on
and I get dragged into it but I promise
you this I'm not trying to make anybody
burn out or be unhappy but let there be
no confusion to this room work ethic is
part of the [ __ ] formula it just is
it just is it might not be fun but like
look you're talking to somebody who put
in zero work ethic into school because I
[ __ ] hated that [ __ ] and so I know
what it feels like to not be motivated
to put in the work if you are not
motivated to put in the work that I'm
talking about you are in the wrong game
you need to take a step back and find
something you're interested in the
amount of people that I know can start a
media site a YouTube channel an
Instagram a tick-tock a podcast and a
vlog around the most narrow [ __ ] star
track the Rams pumpkins like like narrow
ass [ __ ] and make a hundred 200 thousand
a year being super happy about talking
the thing that they love bird [ __ ]
houses do you understand that somebody
in here can make two hundred thousand
dollars a year talking and making
content around birdhouses because for
some unknown reason they [ __ ] love
birdhouses yet because it's only two
hundred thousand in our current culture
that's not good enough it's a billion or
bust it's a hundred million I got to be
a millionaire the one top 1% of earners
in America make four hundred forty
thousand and up if you make four hundred
forty thousand dollars a year or higher
you're in the top 1% of one of the
richest countries if not the richest
country in the world yet our culture
doesn't even begin to give you credit
until you're a millionaire it's [ __ ]
stupid and we have a lot of people
grossly unhappy cuz they're chasing [ __ ]
to spend money to buy dumb [ __ ] to
impress people they don't even like
my friends I come here this afternoon to
talk about a couple of things number one
until this room especially and the
Greater 300 million people in this
country redefine success into waking up
in the morning and being happy versus
money we will be in a bad place some of
this stuff can get very cliche if you're
happy it will come but I'm watching I'm
watching and like making money is a
talent
we accept making we accept being a
basketball player as a talent we accept
being an incredible artist and singing
is a talent for some reason we've
created massive delusion around
everybody can make money it's hard it's
an actual talent and we have to have
that conversation because when we do it
can start getting us into way better
conversations for this room which is
what are you destined to do what are you
capable of doing what makes you happy
how does it go well to me that's where
it gets interesting we live in a time
where the internet is hit scale and it's
still under priced we are so fortunate
our great-grandparents couldn't turn a
side hustle into the real life they had
to work 9:00 to 5:00 and in the world
shut down there was no internet this
internet thing is a blessing
we're demonizing it because what the
Internet's also doing is exposing us the
Internet's not changing us by the way
all the [ __ ] were up to all the terrible
things were up to thank God the
Internet's around a lot of us needed to
see that to realize it was happening we
were delusional we're being exposed
we're not being changed on the flip side
that same power to actually expose us is
the most powerful my friends I see a lot
of you recording holding up your phones
you are sitting with a computer in your
pocket right now that is more powerful
than the computer that Ronald Reagan had
to run the free world that is fax that
is bonkers ass [ __ ]
you can literally post a video right now
on a plot listen again
I am the byproduct of understanding
where organic reach was on tilt and went
all in whether or not was searched
whether that was you know email whether
that was Google AdWords and then later
YouTube and the later Facebook and
Twitter
right now with no followers on tick-tock
and Linkedin none zero you don't have a
count you can go home right now somebody
left a comment today and we looked
somebody's first video on tick tock got
400,000 views we have there's free
awareness there's free awareness and all
you have to do is execute and it costs
nothing I love people some you know I've
been talking a lot about instagrams
organic reach going down right which has
a lot of people worried and I saw a
comment last night where this woman was
like [ __ ] Instagram it's all these
corporations
it's just corporate greed they just want
you to buy ads and I'm like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is free Instagram is free and
by the way you've been around now for a
while this is not 1997 anymore
these platforms have shown you that the
organic reach is free then supply and
demand kicks in and they're running a
business
what are you the only one that's allowed
what you selling [ __ ] Botox tea on
the platform that's free is okay but
them not making some money is it get the
[ __ ] out of here
[Applause]
we are living in the most opportunistic
time in the history of mankind from
communication no but if I was giving
this talk in 1979 nobody here including
myself could afford shooting a satellite
into space to have a TV network nobody
up here was dropping a hundred million
on a printing press we are the media all
you have to do is make we are the media
all you have to do is make and even with
that mitzvah when that great opportunity
of a lifetime one that everybody that
lived before us would break their arms
off to be living here right now at this
time with this cost to be able to build
awareness about their thing even with
all that you're not making you can
imagine why I have zero tears for the
collective it is very hard for me to be
feel sad for anybody who isn't making
content at scale when the blueprint is
black and white please my friends please
use this energy of this talk to do the
following number one go back home and
figure out what kind of communicator are
you not everybody is outrageously
handsome and charismatic on film some of
you are just great at writing as a
matter of fact let me use writing as an
example I think writing is grossly
underestimated you can crush on Twitter
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram I think if
you look at the content that's popping
on Instagram a photo that's fine with an
incredible two or three paragraphs has
enormous potential I think more people
should use Instagram as a blog and back
to blogs the only time since 1997 did I
myself to this moment not take full
advantage of the underpriced moment of
its time it was actually blogging from
2001 to 2004
I am NOT capable of writing you know I
couldn't afford ghost writers to
transcribe the words that are captured
on film like I can now so I had to let
that year ago frustrated
but I knew that I couldn't communicate
back in 2004 before I used Google and by
the way
autocorrect saved my I couldn't spell
[ __ ] in 2002 so I remember that
frustration but I sit here today and I
implore all of you number one who are
you as a communicator do you write I
think memos on the phone with random
thoughts where you just record it I mean
heck use your video and let it be a
picture of the floor and record your
thoughts if you're insecure on video
just record the thoughts record it and
post it if you're not communicating
often daily on Facebook Twitter
Instagram snap YouTube tic toc podcast
if you're not doing that you're not in
the game there's no more time left this
is not debatable anymore you are not in
the game somebody else is taking your
attention
we're not consuming content the same
ways anymore everybody you're trying to
reach is available at such a low cost in
this environment I I can't I can't
figure out the words the piece of
content the thing to get you to finally
let go and and it by the way and I've
never said this publicly if this is
because of deep insecurity you need to
go see a therapist and get that poison
out
there is something holding back that I
need to figure out an enthusiastic crowd
that has so much love for me and I have
so much for them 80% of the people stand
up knowing that LinkedIn tick tock is
the underpriced place from the guy who's
been right now for 15 years about the
underpriced place and yet you still
don't make I have to figure that out
we have to figure that out let me let me
try to chip away at figuring it out
let's make up some new rules rule number
one you post something and somebody
replies that you're ugly somebody
replies that you're a [ __ ] idiot and
you don't know what you're talking about
that you're a clown that you're this
that you're that why why are we affected
by that instead of why don't we start
deploying compassion and empathy for
people that have anonymous accounts
consume your content and then have time
to leave negativity when I see people
[ __ ] on me I feel bad for them I don't
have time to consume content of people
that I admire let alone people that I
think are [ __ ] faces I'm hoping that one
person here who's crippled by negative
feedback and that's why she or he
doesn't post which I believe is actually
a stunningly high percentage of this
room because of the way they grew up
there their self-esteem a million
different variables I'm just trying to
get somebody here to realize that that
negativity actually should be something
that you feel bad for the other person
not for you
I I genuinely believe that bro I feel
bad for them who's got time for nonsense
I don't know number two something I'm
super proud of my sister yesterday
posted something and I had this crazy
trip when I spoke in Asia last year that
I took my sister my sister is wired very
differently than me I'm pure optimism
and positivity
she's citizen she is and she's she's
grown up more insecure than me and
yesterday she posted something and it
reminded me of something and I'm glad
she did because it's gonna inspire me to
tell you this
I believed one of the biggest reasons
that people in here don't post is
because they're actually sitting with a
secret or two and have real insecurities
and that secret is the jail of their
life and they don't want to put
themselves out there because
subconsciously or consciously they
realize that that thing will then come
out and I believe that that is the next
thing I want to talk to you about which
is I call the eight mile rule if you how
many people here have seen eight mile
the eminem movie what he does at the end
of that movie is something I think about
a lot he goes in the final battle rap
and he starts first and he takes a
complete and utter [ __ ] on himself
instead of dissing the other person he
spends the entire rap making fun of
himself leaving the other person nothing
to say I believe one of the breakthrough
moments of this talk from and I'm by the
way I've gotten real practical about the
way I speak I'm hoping to get one person
to do this tonight if I can get one
person to leave this conference right
now go to their car take their iPhone
put on the lights and make a video and
say some [ __ ] that they've been keeping
a secret for their whole life and put it
out there they would be blown away by a
couple of things number one how little
anybody gives a [ __ ]
my friends the high schools it rule as I
call it all of us were scared shitless
we need a big [ __ ] zit we just didn't
realize that we went into school they
had their own zits they had their own
[ __ ] we're so worried about our [ __ ]
like we're the center of the universe
you know what allows me to be super
happy is I think I'm the best that I'm
gonna achieve so much and I know if I
get hit by a bus tomorrow that I'll
trend on Twitter for a couple hours and
you'll all move on your way when you
realize that you're great or you're
hungry or you're trying but you also
realize you're nothing when you can
balance that you're unstoppable my
friends you're holding a secret thank
you
you're holding a secret right now all of
you because we all do all of us you're
holding a secret that you will be
stunned that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
you turn your phone you tell the world X
Y & Z you will be stunned by the freedom
that that opens up in your life and more
importantly by how little and by the way
if there was ever a time to put out your
secrets it's right now there is so much
[ __ ] going on then nobody does nobody
cares that you didn't actually graduate
college or that you did this or you did
that like nobody gives a [ __ ] so if I
can get one of you thank you if I can
get one of you just one of you to leave
here and by the way if you do it if
you've got it in you DM me hit me up on
Twitter I will share it I will
absolutely share it go on there
put the video and don't do some [ __ ]
one because you want to get some
awareness for me [ __ ] you guys I know
how you roll don't make it up I need
some real ass [ __ ] I need to see your
auntie in there saying oh [ __ ] I can't
believe you did this I will spend the
next year two three years and it's the
first time I've shared this a lot of you
could sue my kind I've never talked
about what I just talked about this
thought of there's something you're
holding in that you're scared will get
exposed if you get too big thus you're
suppressing yourself I will continue to
add new things to my repertoire because
I'm thinking about every single thing
that is stopping you from actually
posting every day 50 times a day
one of the things that allows me to go
so hard is I'm not scared
I'm eight mile I am what I am it's all
been easy for me like it is what it is
I'm living on the record I have 25
people in my inbox some idea people have
access to all my [ __ ]
I'm not worried I'm not living in the
shadows and I don't want you either
because when you don't it's a lot more
fun it's a lot easier I think about this
era in American history has one step
back for two steps forward because we
had to deal with a lot of collective
pain forget your political status or
things that nature we are seeing so much
of what we needed to see and in that is
such a great opportunity I genuinely
believe that I think one thing that I am
noticing already is people are least
challenging themselves to have a little
bit more compassion and empathy they're
starting to understand some of the
nuances right now we're still in a
little bit of like holding our ground
but we're getting tired you know people
what's great about humans is we're
grossly underrated this is why we're
still here deep down we are very good
collectively and so I'm starting to see
that and in that I hope that encourages
you to realize everybody's got something
everybody's got something it's true and
so whether it's you're insecure and the
judgment of others stops you from making
and I'm hoping that I made you realize
you shouldn't feel bad for you you feel
bad for them whether it's you got some
sort of secret that you think is [ __ ]
up but in the reality things it should
okay I mean look if you murder somebody
you might want to keep that [ __ ] but you
know what you know but like put it out
there let go you will be blown away that
might be the unlock by the way and this
next one's very real I think a lot of
you actually don't believe in what
you're selling I think one of the things
that's holding you back and one of the
things that allows me to go so hard is I
actually think somewhere deep down you
don't believe in it you believe in the
good money that comes along with it but
deep down you don't believe in it and
your moral compass even if it's hidden
deep in your gut isn't letting you go
all the way so number three is please
take a look at what your
selling I think a lot of you don't
believe in it because a lot of it is
based around you and you know you
haven't done that thing yet you're just
posturing there's way too many people
that still believe in fake it till you
make it without realizing the internet
changed that game it was easy to fake it
to make it in 1980s nobody knew what the
[ __ ] was going on now it's real hard
because data is everywhere and so I'd
highly recommend you give that some
thought
and finally this if I could wish one
thing for this room as a tactic that is
completely left field it is for you to
go and donate some of your time to a
retirement home I've been talking a lot
about I used to do it way back when
thank you I'm actually gonna do I think
we got d-roc we got one scheduled for
February I think right for the vlog so
here's why I like it I think there's an
incredible opportunity for a lot of
people in here to go and volunteer eight
hours of their time at their local
retirement home because I think spending
time with people in their 90's 80s
hundreds that aren't your grandparents
is an incredible perspective I think
what you'll learn if you spend time with
them is regret is really scary so much
of who I am is the fact that in my early
years as a kid I would spend a lot of
time with the grandparents of my friends
I was always drawn to the much older
than me in that something triggered and
I kept building on that in my 20s which
is regret scares me
there's I've never seen anything that
scares me as much as sitting with
somebody in their 80s or 90s who spends
all their time talking to me and not
about not what they did but what they
wish they did and in that there's
something that I think could really work
here and here's what I mean by that I
believe that if everybody in this room
had a better relationship with
understanding time they could be much
happier I feel like people are grossly
impatient I don't think that people that
are 55 years old realized they have 20
more years of executing in a world where
they grew up as kids and 55 seems so old
and people were dying at a different age
and retiring
different age I think if you actually
saw regret up-close-and-personal for one
day that a lot of the things that you're
not doing then it could scare you into
doing it I live a life already where
people email me on a tactical level the
regret that they wish they listen to me
around this that or the other thing
three or four or five years ago I am
good at my craft which means today I can
tell you about tick tock and Linkedin
and tomorrow might be something else and
if they all go off the face of the earth
and it's all new stuff I'll be great at
that too because my singular skill is
what consumers do the behavior of you
not the platform of the moment I will
spend probably the rest of my life
trying to figure out how to unlock
people to make because communication is
always the foundation of success your
relationships with your loved ones your
employees your customers your audience
is completely predicated on
communication it's true it's true
and I have to figure out why you're not
communicating and I will and I'll keep
hacking until my last breath but I
implore you please don't watch this
exact talk in seven years when I read it
up because there's some new platform
called lipstick or cloud face or haha
and I talk about all the people that one
I'm tick-tock and LinkedIn and by the
way if tick-tock becomes vine let me
remind everybody this vine had a year
run right one year right but as you know
my friend and everybody else hears
hundreds of the people that built their
fame their awareness on vine went on to
leverage that on snap and now are some
of the biggest people on Instagram and
are some people like attention comes
with you my friends the reason I build
me not anything else but me not
Instagram expert 49 not crypto guy six
know me is because it comes with me if
all of these disappear if they all
disappear if the government comes along
and says they're all out lawd and now
we're doing our own thing like China and
there's one app haha calm when you sign
up you're gonna type in Gary Vee to find
me on that platform it comes with you
and so thank you and so please take
advantage of the underpriced
opportunities right now please figure
out how to make content that's good for
them not for you I come up here and I
give a talk for this 45 minutes that's
good for you not good for me you
understand that is what you need to do
when you produce content it doesn't need
to be a piece of content that's actually
a top of the funnel thing to get them
into your funnel to get them into
conversion it needs to be something that
actually brings some what value period
end of story SIA to build a motion and
equity
my friends when this is all said and
done it's gonna end up very simple
whoever brings the most value to their
audience will win
we love Amazon because we get stuff at
good prices deliver to us the next day
we like that you may not like other
things they do or this and the other
thing or whatever is your political
point whatever but you like getting what
you want at the best price immediately
we as humans to get what we want
have to figure out how to bring value to
them in the places where they consume
information until you figure that out
you'll keep looking for the hack the one
that doesn't exist thank you thank you
Thank You Li I love you guys thank you
so much
[Applause]